d'après vous monsieur ce qu'il faut
reconnaître ou non le vote blanc bien
évidemment qu'il faut le reconnaître
parce que là on ne se rend pas compte
qu'il ya une colère qui monte et on ne
la prend pas en considération
oui il faut le reconnaître mais en même
temps pour demander pourquoi pourquoi
les gens sont beaux ciblons mais on ne
va pas les compter parce que ça les gens
ont fait les banques avec maison
touron qu est-ce que chez vous en
angleterre on le compte alors ce vote
blanc on est bon je sais pas j'ai aucune
idée
c'est une vraie question je pense que
oui
pour quelle raison parce qu'il exprime
quelque chose et que c'est important
d'en tenir compte et d'analyser un peu
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans notre
démocratie défaillante
ouais je pense quand même que le vote
blanc a son importance parce que nos
jours lorsqu'enfin lors des élections
lorsque quelqu'un est élu
généralement c'est on le compte sur le
nombre des personnes qui ont voté en
fait donc un candidat qui re 70% des
voix vous quand ces voix représente que
20% des gens qu en actionnant voter oui
il est élu mais il n'a pas vraiment été
élus porteront donc le vote blanc il
devrait évidemment il devrait compter de
nos jours il doit être connue mais ça
nous fait aussi rentrer dans un point
négatif du fait qu' on peut se retrouver
coincé avec un système gouvernemental ou
des élections qui sont en attente en
fait d'avoir des gens qui votent pas ce
que c'est aujourd'hui 80% des gens de
votre pass chiffres au hasard qu'est ce
qui nous dit qu'au deuxième tour 3e tour
4e tour qu'on va nous faire en boucle on
n'aura pas encore un taux d'absence
d'abstention supérieur à 50% qui
rendront les élections qui a dit quoi
oui il faut reconnaître le vote blanc ça
prouve que les gens ne sont pas d'accord
sur les listes il faut les compter parce
que ils sont jamais contée et ça
représente aussi un gros pourcentage
il faudrait en tenir compte
moi je comprends pas pourquoi ce n'est
pas obtenue en compte depuis des années
et des années
là je sais pas combien vu de votre blanc
je ne sais pas je peux regarder en fait
mais ça doit être conséquent parce qu'on
dit que les gens sont pas allés aux
urnes mais parce que même s'ils votent
blanc ça compte pas donc voilà je
comprends pourquoi ils n'y vont pas il
faut peut-être que le gouvernement se
pose la question et à savoir pourquoi
les gens votent blanc
il faut peut-être avoir une réflexion à
ce sujet pourquoi les gens votent blanc
pour - oui tout à fait parce que ça veut
dire que les gens ont quand même fait la
démarche
donc ils ont l'intention de voter et ça
exprime quand même un mécontentement
quelque part parce que la personne ont
fait signifie qu'elle est responsable qu
elle est citoyenne
mais en même temps
il ya un ras-le-bol ya une confusion et
pour exprimer en fait cette confusion je
trouve que ça serait nécessaire oui de
reconnaître le vote blanc voilà alors je
pense qu'il faudrait prendre en compte à
ce moment là c'est ce pourcentage parce
que c'est très parlant
et peut-être effectivement ou refaire
reprogrammé l'élection en tout cas je
pense que oui ça sera nécessaire de les
prendre en compte
voilà